- [Voiceover] Let's do some examples
creating picture and bar graphs.
So it says Mr. Smith
assigned a special project
about the ocean to the students
in his Earth Science class.
To find out if students
who spend more time
on their projects got better grades,
he asked the students how much time
they spent completing their projects.
Create a bar graph to show how much time
each student spent
completing the ocean project.
So James spent 36 minutes.
So I'm gonna click here
and I'm gonna move this up to 36.
Eji spent 54 minutes.
So I'm gonna move this up to 54 minutes.
Then Minli spent 36 minutes.
So I'm gonna move Minli up to 36 minutes.
Then Simone spent 30 minutes.
So I'm gonna move Simone up to 30.
Then Kiran spent 12 minutes.
So I'll move Kiran up to 12.
And there you go, I have
constructed the bar graph.
Let's do a couple more of these.
All right.
So on Thursday, Ming went to see a loud
and exciting performance
by the Dinosaur Orchestra.
Create a bar graph to show how many
of each type of dinosaur were
in the Dinosaur Orchestra.
So I guess there were 42 Stegosaurus's.
I don't know if that's a
plural for Stegosaurus.
So there are 42 Stegosaurus's,
63 Raptors.
So we move the Raptor up to 63.
35 Triceratops.
Then you had 49 Tyrannosaurus.
49 of these.
So fairly straightforward.
So let's do a couple more of these.
All right, so now it tells
us Rose's flower shop
makes bouquets for special occasions.
Each bouquet comes with
a different number of flowers.
Create a picture graph to show the number
of flowers in each bouquet.
So this is kind of like a bar graph,
but instead we're gonna use pictures.
Each picture shows a certain number.
So in this case, a picture of a flower
represents three flowers.
So the Mother's day
bouquet has 21 flowers.
So 21 flowers.
Now you might be tempted
to put 21 pictures
of flowers here, but you have to remember
each of these flowers
represent three flowers.
So one way to think about it,
you could count by threes.
Three, six, nine,
12, 15, 18, 21.
So that over here, this right over here,
would represent 21 flowers.
And you notice I just made
seven of this picture,
and that makes sense because seven
of these pictures, and
each of these pictures
represent three flowers,
seven times three is 21.
The Mother's Day bouquet
has 21 flowers in it.
All right, the Anniversary
bouquet has 27 flowers.
So three, six, nine,
12, 15, 18, 21, 24, 27.
I have nine flowers here.
Nine times three is 27.
The Birthday bouquet has 18.
So three, six, nine, 12, 15, 18.
And I just made six pictures here
because each of them
represent three flowers.
Six times three is 18.
Then finally, the Congratulations bouquet
has 12 flowers in it.
Three, six, nine, and 12.
There you go.
I think we're done.
Let's do one more of these.
All right.
Barry Bee and his bee friends love
to pollinate flowers.
They created a chart and a picture graph
to show how many flowers each
of them pollinated today.
Use the information in the chart
to answer the question
about the picture graph.
So it says, On the picture graph,
each flower equals blank flowers,
or each picture of a flower, I should say,
equals a blank number of flowers.
So it says Barry pollinated 27.
These are impressive bees
that they sit there making charts.
Barry pollinated 27 flowers,
and they only drew three pictures here.
So these three flower
pictures must represent 27.
So the way that they would represent 27
is if each of these represent nine
because we'd have nine, 18, 27.
So each of these must be nine flowers.
But let's see if that works.
So for Bumbly, 63.
So let's see, nine, 18, 27,
36, 45, 54, 63.
Yep, it looks like it works out.
Betty is one, two, three, four, five, six.
Six, six times nine is 54.
That is the number of
flowers she pollinated.
Bertie, one, two, three, four, five.
If each of those pictures represent nine,
then this would be five times nine is 45.
That is the number of flowers Bertie
had actually pollinated.